done a book on poetry poetry and music
for the many I love poetry we can agree
on
that on TV on Radio and on your
smartphone this is talk
TV how you going to stop the votes this
is an international problem how's that
going for your party I'm a millennial
you're a Victorian
this helps weather people I'm going to
help the vet
[Music]
office Tado appears Morgan uncensored in
New York City a big breaking news story
tonight an unprecedented double Royal
Health crisis as both the king and the
Princess of Wales admitted to hospital
both say it's planned but they both
cancel public engagements a short notice
we'll have over the latest
the UK government looks set to survive
another test for what I think is its
crackpot plan to send illegal migrants
to Rwanda but with a border crisis on
both sides of the Atlantic could
immigration bring down two governments
and elections this year we'll debate
that and Trump's at the stump with a
rare call for Unity could he really
ditch his election denying dire tribes
and win back to presidency I'll talk to
Maga Maestro carry Lake and the tough
talking governor who still says it has
to be Nikki Haley
live from New York this is Piers Morgan
uncensored good evening from New York
City and welcome to Piers Morgan
uncensored there are two massive
elections this year in which immigration
will be a decisive Factor here in the
United States is an escalating crisis at
the southern border more than 300,000
people were processed in December alone
a new record tens of thousands of
migrants are being pushed around the
country by bus and by plane border towns
have declared a state of emergency in
the United Kingdom net migration is
higher than any time in recorded history
and the government is struggling to meet
its core pledge to stop illegal
immigrants crossing the English Channel
in small boats the big difference here
is that voters believe the conservative
Republicans can fix it immigration was a
number one issue in the Iowa caucus
where voters just propelled Donald Trump
to an historic Landslide Victory and he
talked on immigration back at home the
conservative party has presided over the
collapse of our immigration system and
it continues to tear itself apart over a
single gimmick policy which I don't
think will ever make any noticeable
difference at all tonight it looks like
the government Will Survive its test for
its crackpot plan to send a handful of
illegal immigrants to Rwanda but it will
then move on to the house of laws and
inevitably end up back in the court and
so on the bottom line is whatever
happens I don't think it's going to work
and certainly not time to help Rishi
tens of thousands of people are crossing
the channel illegally every year they
enter a broken and chaotic system
kneecap by chronic backlogs sending a
tiny number of people to East Africa at
a cost of nearly £170,000 a person never
seemed to me a practical or Humane
solution so why the repeated
self-inflicted chaos we've seen
rebellions resignations and legal
ramifications Galore but more
journalists and ministers have flown to
Rwanda than actual migrants from
Minister Ser sunat looks like one of
those cartoon characters repeatedly
stepping on a rake as a handle whacks
him in the face well sunat made a smart
deal with the Albanian Premier to send
illegal Albanian migrants back home they
were mostly young economic male migrant
looking for a better life the number of
albanians crossing the channel has now
fallen by 90% And as a consequence the
number of people coming over on the
small boats fell by nearly a third that
is the kind of pragmatic intelligent
solution I expect from a sharp
business-minded prime minister we need
more of that Mr sunak and less of these
gimmicks the Statesman like thing to do
I think would be for richat to say you
know what this isn't going to work it's
just not going to work certainly in the
time frame I needed to and we're going
to get on right now we fixing the mess
now the labor party doesn't have any
better ideas they're just cashing in on
the
chaos day
643 perhaps of the Rwanda Psycho Drama
that the conservative party continues to
inflict on our weary and baffled nation
and so vast quantities of political
capital and untold amounts of government
time resources and energy have been
squandered on a policy that at most
might possibly one day enable the
transfer of a few hundred Asylum Seekers
to
Rwanda well the poisonous Paradox in
Britain is that the conservatives have
talked up in immigra Immigration as a
crisis while simultaneously jacking up
legal migration to cover gaps in the
workforce and that bluff is now being
decisively called and on both sides of
the Atlantic it's not a case of
xenophobia racism or voters being
anti-immigration both countries are
almost uniquely welcoming to migrants we
need their skills their labor their
ideas our doors should be open to people
fleeing Wars especially when they are
Wars that we may have started and the
evidence says that we are but it has to
be sustainable if you don't have a board
order you don't have a country and
voters this year will punish leaders who
get this vital issue
wrong well we'll get into that debate in
a moment but first that breaking news
today on a double Royal Health crisis
Bucky and Palace announcing that King
Charles on new monarch will undergo
surgery for an enlarged prostate next
week postponing all his public
engagements while Katherine the Princess
of Wales has already undergone abdominal
surgery yesterday the princess hasn't
been seen in public since Christmas
she'll now remain in hospital for up to
two weeks we're told and has cancelled
all public duties until at least Easter
in April well Jo how discuss all this
has talked to his Ro editor Sarah
Houston who's in London and in studio
with me here in New York his Fox News
contributor Dr Mark SE welcome to both
of you uh Sarah Sarah let's get to the
the Royal story aspect of this I can't
remember the last time there were two
announcements like this back to back um
both supposedly for Planned procedures
but it all seemed a bit rushed out to me
what's your take on this yeah and I
suppose it depends what they mean by
planned uh doesn't it Piers we're told
that the Princess of Wales wasn't rushed
into hospital this isn't something that
occurred over the course of the weekend
and has then led to her being
hospitalized this week but we don't know
for how long it has been planned in the
king's case he started to uh feel
symptoms he then saw a doctor earlier on
this week and he received his diagnosis
today and that led to the announcement
from Buckingham Palace that he was going
to undergo a procedure next week now
it's not ideal is it for them to have to
make two major announcements about uh
the most senior member of the royal
family and the second most senior female
uh member of the royal family within an
hour and a half of each other now bak
and pal stressing that what the king is
to undergo next week is very much
routine it is something that many many
men of his age will undergo and he will
uh undergo it for a short period of time
he'll have a short period of
recuperation where engagements will be
canceled but because of his symptoms
he's actually had to cancel engagements
that were due to take place tomorrow and
Friday a much more serious uh case for
the Princess of Wales because while this
was planned surgery and we're told it
was successful a 10 to 14 day stay in
hospital followed by two to three months
of recuperation tells us that this was
major surgery uh for the Princess of
Wales and we've got the Prince of Wales
William her husband also now canceling
engagements and taking time off work to
be at his wife's side and also looking
after their three young children so a
significant impact on the royal family
and their ability to go about their
duties yeah absolutely um let's turn to
to Dr Mark eagle from a medical
perspective Charles is obviously more
straightforward situation he's a man in
his 70s he's got an enlarged prostate
that's not an uncommon condition for men
of that age but the procedure itself he
is the monarch um will he be put under
for this and what will happen absolutely
and by the way Sarah said it it might
have happened precipitously what usually
happens is these symptoms acrew over
many months or years over the age of 70
80% of men have in llarge prostates they
don't all need procedures but when the
medications fail and it's not stopping
it so that you get an Easy Flow you have
a procedure and it's all about urine
flow within a large prostate exactly and
if if it doesn't you if you if you if it
suspended the flow or it interferes with
the flow you may have a procedure
usually these days Piers we're using a
green laser which actually is is quite a
a small way to go about it it's not a
big open procedure it's it's through the
urethra but it as Sarah just said it can
work and be you're done with it in an
hour maybe you're home the next day to
your point though it is done on under
General anesthesia generally propol
which everybody's heard about that's the
Michael Jackson drug we use that for
colonoscopies for any procedure but also
ketamine so ketamine propol plus
ketamine is the usual are we going to
have King Charles and ketamine storm is
that the headline next I hope not but he
he will probably go why why ketam in
what does that well because it puts you
under more Pro propal is is just a
milder lighter anesthesia but again this
is an actual procedure I thought K was
an elephant tranquilizer initially AB
absolutely you you have that right back
in the 70s that's what they started for
you're literally evaporating part of the
prostate with this the the front part
that's pinching on the urethra you're
literally using the laser to evaporate
it if you don't have that procedure what
happens ultimately well after a while
the medications fail and you would have
to have an open procedure which again is
the old scalpel method where we're
through with that now this is this is a
miracle for step forward will it have
any side effects going forward after
he's had the procedure for a few days
after you might have some burning when
you urinate some hesitancy when you
urinate a little bit of pain but then it
gradually responds over a few days not
like what we're hearing for the princess
right so this looks altogether more
serious and the fact we're not being
told what it is suggests there something
more serious going on for someone of 42
and otherwise in very good health to be
in hospital for up to two weeks and then
have basically three months off work
what does that tell you this might be
I'm concerned about this uh I I like the
point that s just made that it was
planned but what does Planned mean I
believe them when they say it's not
cancer so that's very very good point
could it be a benign tumor could it be a
hernia could it be a gynecological
procedure could it be related to she had
three children in five years which is a
lot but she was out there saying I used
hypnotherapy for this so now she's she's
re relying on privacy and that makes me
concern but Pierce almost every single
abdominal surgery I can think of that's
not an emergency it's done through a
scope these days or robot and you're
home in a day so I'm concerned so what
what what could it be I think something
might have gone wrong I'm worried about
a complication I'm worried about an
infection you know she went in there
maybe something happened she wasn't
anticipating and two to three months of
recovery implies that there's been
something major here so it may not have
been a planned major surgery but how do
we know an infection didn't Ur how do we
know a complication didn't occur she's
going to be fine I have a strong feeling
she'll be fine but the longer term
recovery concerns me that something went
wrong
Sarah where does this leave us if King
Charles is
unconscious and William is you know
looking after his kids and I mean do we
start heading down the list of people if
there's some Duty that the Monarch has
to perform what actually happens here
we're kind of into Uncharted Territory a
bit well look there's a very set
procedure in place should a monarch be
incapacitated due to ill health for a
short period of time and and if the king
does have to undergo a general
anesthetic and is unconscious then the
councilors of state would be called upon
should they be needed now the list of
the councilors of state is the the
Monarch spouse so Camila and the next
four in line to the throne traditionally
now that list throws up a few problems
as you've alluded to their peers because
it's the Prince of Whales who we know is
looking after his wife and children then
it's Prince Harry who's in California
the next on the list the Duke of's going
to be he won't be interim King will he
no he won Duke of your princess be stay
here but in planning for an occasion
like this uh the royal family decided
that might be pertinent to add a couple
more onto the list so we now have uh the
Princess Royal who is also a counselor
of state and the Duke of Edinburgh so
should they be required they could be
called on but I think it's highly likely
that the king will only be out of action
for a very short period of time and
while he's not conducting public duties
he'll still be receiving his red boxes
he'll still be able to make decisions uh
as and when there
all right Sarah Houston London thank you
very much Dr Mar great to see you great
to see you welcome to New York oh thank
you I love New York you know I do and I
hope to come get you back next time I'm
here absolutely s next whether it's
small boats from UK or a so-called
invasion of America's Southern border
immigration May well be decisive in
elections on both sides of the Atlantic
this year my Super PAC joins me to
discuss that next live from New
[Music]
York
we're here thanks for joining us you're
with talk TV on TV on radio online onun
your smart speaker as well criminals to
using XL Bully dogs as weapons to
threaten others no matter how well
trained most dog owners will tell you a
dog can turn you know what I love about
talk today we do it all sunak sella
scon I rather like David Cameron I don't
sort of bear him any ill will because he
delivered the referendum that he said he
would deliver the Tories love a scrap
you can almost see this coming around
the tracks with sella bravman she's
heading up one side and richy soon at
the other the police are pro Palestine
that is just not right you swearing off
in the police to act without fear or
favor the co inquiry seems to have
turned into a sort of pantomim there's
not really any substance to it it's hard
to know whether it's a fce or a
tragedy the amount of time it's taken
the number of illegal migrants currently
sent by us to Rwanda zil the amount of
money it's cost we're saying what are we
saying it's cost about 140 million 1440
million so far so £40 million so far
result nil absolutely nil are we only
going to be trusting sources like meta
and Google where is our unbiased news
going to come from Kell in winter is
cold that is from the Jeremy Corbin book
Kevin O Sullivan is the worst presenter
on talk TV sitting on his fat ass
talking
if you're walking towards me and you're
a vegan you have a great big orange
sticker over here saying watch out
vegan's
about the weirdest plank that we've had
in about three years hundreds and
hundreds of mice in a box which he walks
into a branch of McDonald MC Mouse man
MC mous man MC M he should be easy
enough to catch this guy shouldn't he I
mean he's got a house full of
mice this is a major Summit President
Biden decided this was important after
watching a Tom Cruz
film sunak and the current conservative
government are not conservative why
don't you leave that party and come to
one that actually shares your ideology
this has been a party political
broadcast onf the reform UK
party kids think all they have to do is
take pictures of everything just shut
down Tik Tok problem solve this is
really unfair what what what's unfair if
it's on camera we're not doing
interviews yes I'm going to do you're
going to resol yes cuz I cannot continue
my work when I say I am God I'm not did
you feel Elvis was controlling I've been
answering your question you answer mine
it's actually not my job to answer your
questions are you prepared to call h a
terror group is it possible to have a
rational I've asked you two questions
should Hass stay in power and are they a
terror group you're refusing to answer
either of them that is very telling talk
TV is the only place where you get the
truth you've done a book on poetry
poetry and music for the many I love
pury we can agree on
that
welcome back to P sensored live from New
York City joining me now is Fox Nation
host Tyrus Fox new contributor cat Tim
and former conservative MP Luise mench a
veritable super pack If Ever I saw one
uh immigration let's start with you tus
because whether you're in the UK and
it's a constant debate now on two levels
one the illegal numbers coming in on
small boats across the channel to try
and get into Britain that way and then
surging numbers of legal migrants coming
with all their dependent family numbers
rocketing to record levels too and then
you have here this extraordinary
situation on the southern border which
seems to be completely out of control
it's a migration and no one's doing
anything about it right so migration and
immigration legal and legal could end up
being a Tipping Point we'd saw from the
Iowa caucus what people were saying
immigration is their key concern it
could be the thing that decides both the
US and UK election which may be
happening in the same month you know
when when I just to the Iowa thing real
quick when I saw that that was the
number one concern concerns me
because it's a is that the talking point
concern because the good people of Iowa
don't have much to worry about in terms
of immigration especially this time of
year pretty safe like the winners I went
to school in Nebraska you you only it
only got colder if you went to Iowa but
uh we've got 3 million court dates I
think that are backlog for 10 years so
even the people who are doing it right
can't do it right because of just it
it's a migration of just basically looks
like countries are just emptying their
prisons they're emptying anybody doesn't
want to be here go the gates have been
open there's been some secret handshake
signal that we weren't aware about in
America so the the big concern is that
you're hearing it where you would think
the argument would be something else in
Iowa so I'm concerned it's becoming a
republican talking point opposed to
actual the states that are really being
affected now if it if we pull New York
and immigration is number one then then
the Republicans might have something to
get excited about but we're we're just
not seeing it in the places where we
should be seeing it in America C how
much is this going to help Trump I mean
c he had a massive victory in Iowa
immigration was the number one thing he
always talks tough on immigration he
didn't build his wall last time the
message was clear if he gets a chance he
will finish the job how much does always
help him well I think it depends on how
much Trump is willing to help himself in
terms of actually staying on message
because Democrats obviously they want
this election to be about Trump and
Trump is bad and January 6 and all these
other things all too often I think what
Trump does is he likes to get in the in
the ring with those people and sort of
fight with them and he will not focus so
much on issues like immigration or like
the economy and immigration in general I
mean the same system we've had in place
in the 9s we we we are not built for
this level of influx of people but I
think that each political side they feel
very comfortable arguing about it and
it's a winning issue right I think that
Republicans say look at this this is out
of control and the Democrats can pull
say oh Republicans are heartless and
they just fight with each other fight
with each other fight with each other
nothing gets solved because for their
political careers it doesn't really
benefit them to solve it but when that
issue doesn't get solved all the rest of
us lose you see and also the debate back
in the UK Louise you know anyone in the
last few years who's dared to raise
concerns about Rising immigration has
immediately been branded a racist and
you see the same thing over here when in
fact most people I know in the UK have a
genuine legitimate concern and it's on
two levels really it's one whether the
huge volumes of legal migrants that
we're taking in many of whom doing
important jobs but bringing with them
because of government policy a lot of
family members are putting massive
strain on an already over creaking
infrastructure not least the National
Health Service education and so on which
I think is a perfect legitimate concern
not withstanding we need good skilled
workers to come in but then you have the
issue of a small boats much smaller
numbers but the Optics of people just
rocking up in these dingies not to
mention the danger and the fact these
horrible criminal gangs are running it
is really resonating with people they
want this to stop sunak to his credit
has actually stopped it by a third with
the Albania deal where it turned out
they're all young migrants from Albania
men wanting to to make a few quid so
been successful there why Rwanda I just
don't know why you can just get rid of
this stupid plan well I think if you
want to deport people if you want to
sort of disincentivize those criminal
gangs who are trafficking in human
misery and causing people to drown and
they don't give a damn about them you've
got to make it not fruitful you've got
to take away the prize at the end of it
it's really pavlovian if you like if you
come over here you will be immediately
deported to Rwanda and we will process
your claim over there uh this is what
the Republicans by the way also want on
the southern border they don't want to
pass Ukraine funding unless Biden gets
rid of parole which is exactly the same
thing it's where you cross the border
illegally and then you can apply for
Asylum inside the United States the
Republicans want that to go away and
really as you say this is more of an
emotional issue than anything else and
politicians need to understand that the
immigration crisis in the UK is not from
the small boats that is a tiny fraction
of the immigration numbers it is from
legal immigration I wish the rebels who
have now given up in tonight's uh most
of them have given up in tonight's vote
had just got them not happening I think
for another yeah it's not and a it looks
it looks all the signs are that Ry sunak
will prevail yeah exactly if they wanted
to really do something about immigration
they should be tackling legal
immigration and where our rules our laws
are at how many people you can bring in
ETC because that's where the real
numbers are coming from it is yeah okay
let's turn to Ben and Jerry's one of my
favorite companies because on the list
of woke virtue signaling imbecilic firms
in the world there they are um you just
think just give me some damn ice cream
and shut up about everything else but
they cannot stop making statements
they've just demanded Ben and Jerry's
board of directors a permanent and
immediate ceasefire in Gaza okay um but
it's the latest of endless
pronouncements by people that make ice
cream right well how' it Go was there a
sh I always like you know did it work
did Jerry's cutting off ice cream wrap
it up fellas serious is not a drill
everyone wants ice cream why do these
companies do this I'm aren't they
supposed to give their company back to
Native Americans weren't their their
headquarters on Native American land so
why have we still been in Jerry
shouldn't it be something else ha
something like this is the thing about
virtue signaling it sounds great you
many high fives like yes we just we just
stopped what's going on in Israel high
five because we threatened to not sell
ice cream to people who support like
this is this is the problem it sounds
good we're talking about it which means
we're all dumber for it they continue to
like these virtue signaling but they
don't actually really do anything and
again you're right just shut up and put
the ice cream on the cone or in the bowl
some sprinkles cat would you ever buy
would you ever buy an ice cream because
of a political position taken by the
people that were making it absolutely
not would you that question but was
delicious conversy would you actively go
cuz I would I'm now at the stage where I
would actively go out of my way to avoid
buying a Ben and Jerry's ice cream
because it annoys me see I'm also not
there uh as somebody see I'm not left or
right so if I only bought you just eat
the ice cream yeah if I only bought
things that agreed with me politically I
would never eat again I would probably
have no friends uh you know all the
people I think who have my political
views like live out in the woods with an
artillery of weapons so I I would really
is looking good right now wood it's like
a good option to me Louise virtu
signaling companies are not new but
there seems to be a proliferation of
them now and they seem to be actively
going out of their way to annoy vast
sways of their customer base if you're a
Jewish person who likes Ben and Jerry's
ice cream you'll be looking at this
going where was this after October the
7th why didn't you call for anything
then so clearly you have a partisan bias
against us so why should I eat your
product exactly um people back home may
not know that Ben and Jerry as we like
to say have previous on July the 4th uh
last year they called for giving Mount
Rushmore back to the Native Americans
because America is so horrible it was
founded on Stolen land not their own
stolen land not their own but not their
own stolen land when Putin invaded
Ukraine this same guy uh Ben Cohen I
think his name is of Ben and Jerry's he
blamed NATO and the US and he put a
million dollars into campaigning for
America not to give Ukraine weapons to
defend them
he blamed everybody except Russia now
these people are Bernie Bros what we
call champagne socialist the Americans
call limousine liberals and I think
there's nothing to pick between hardcore
people on the right the alt right and
hardcore people on the alt left they're
all just extremist nonsense I wish I
could boycott Ben and Jerry's but I
never eat it because it's an inferior
ice
cream well it is a little heavy on the
calories we being fair it's obviously if
you have a body like this you don't eat
ice cream at all so that's uh that's a
given um want to play a clip from my my
one of my favorite people kamla Harris
not for the reason she would like to be
one of my favorite people she appeared
on The View today um which by the way
how annoying is The View getting God
they're insufferable that a lot aren't
they um just a just a side of effect but
she told Joy Bahar that she's scared as
heck and we should all be scared about
the prospect of Donald Trump getting
reelected by and let's see what she said
here this is by who watch this are you
scared first of all what could happen if
Trump ever became God forbid president
again and what are you going to do to
stop the
crazies I am scared as
heck yeah which is why I'm traveling our
country you know there's an old saying
that there are only two ways to run for
office either without an opponent or
scared so on all of those points yes we
should all be scared and no attempt to
correct Joy bear tus when she uses that
phrase crazies about people who may
support Trump this reminded me of
Hillary Clinton with her basket of
deplorables Jive about what is in
reality tens of millions of Americans
listen uh you can't compare it to
Hillary Clinton because Hillary made a
concise direct argument whether you
agree with her or not she was pretty
clear when she spoke I still have no
idea what Auntie kamla just said and I
know it's early but I was hoping that
the wine wouldn't be served till after
the interview that was a loaded question
that was preapproved so when you're not
cat we on the gut fill show we bring
this up quite a bit when you don't have
anything to run on that you want to
discuss because you might get off on a
tangent or not know what you're talking
about you and I have discussed this
feelings yeah you can discuss feelings
I'm afraid so I can't be wrong no one
can argue with Auntie kamla that she's a
afraid and even though you'll say but
you are the VP and you have the top five
armies in the world and you're afraid of
a little old man with orangish red hair
comb over why would you PR what does he
what did he do to you like this is the
VP of the United States of America and
she's afraid no this is the talking
point there's no substance what do you
do for
schools I'm afraid I'm afraid uh you
know in the UK we're panicking now that
we may end up with King Harry if we're
not if we're not very lucky um um you
could end up you know Heartbeat Away
famously from potentially president
Harris yeah your thoughts on that
Prospect potentially I think that when I
think about what concerns me the most it
actually would be the exact kind of
rhetoric that we heard on that show
right because when we talk about people
oh The Crazies then you're reducing
these people to this you pit people
against each other everybody loses the
only group that doesn't lose is the
members of the government right because
if you're voting against the other side
because they're evil then that motivates
people to vote for you but also when you
turn people against each other it
convinces people to willingly give up
their own rights for sake of this evil
other we saw a lot of this especially
since Trump enters has entered politics
and I and I really fear that it's going
to get a lot worse in terms of us
willingly hating each other based on
preconceived notions that someone else
who doesn't know you or care about you
or your relationships has told you to
think I think that's so true the langu
the demonizing language on both sides
actually has really red it up civilized
debate between politicians or about
politicians is is just disappeared yeah
I watched the interview and I actually
thought KLA did a skillful job in
avoiding uh bombs that were set out for
her by The View whether intentionally or
not I don't agree with you that she
should have said something about the
crazies because what I heard from Joy B
who also wasn't very coherent there I
thought she was talking about Trump and
his team as being the craziest rather
than the Trump voters as he says I don't
think you can compare it to Hillary
direct insult Trump voters are a basket
of deplorables that may or may not have
been a reference to Trump voters as
opposed to the campaign who knows she
didn't say anything negative about them
she was also asked if she agreed with
Nikki Haley that America had never been
a racist country and she skillfully I
thought avoided saying yes America has
been racist she totally avoided that it
was a little bit word salad but her job
now is at the moment her job is not to
mess up and I think in the campaign
Trail what you will see Carla Harris
concentrating on is the one one really
big winning issue that the Democrats
have which is abortion there are a lot
of Women Voters even GOP Women Voters
who are mad as hell about Row versus
Wade going away doesn't matter what you
think about it it's a huge election
winner for the Democrats and that's what
Carla as the woman in the white house
will be concentrating on well the other
just quickly we don't got much time here
tus but Michelle Obama turns 60 today
happy birthday to the former first lady
a lot of people putting her name out
there is potentially the SA
for the Democrat Party could she be I
have no idea what her politics are so I
can't answer that question I think every
time she steps out of a plane because
she's so beloved by a vast majority of
the American people that they want to
say oh yes because for while was Oprah
then for a little bit it was even the
rock like they're they just pick people
they this is who we have Joe Biden is
running for election even if he were to
pass on he would come down from heaven
to show up to be there he is running
this this IDE a that he's just going to
let go and just oh sure come on in
Michelle the the the Obama Biden
relationship we I think the right likes
to think is a close relationship but
it's not I don't think it is it's not at
all but I to say uh I met the Obama on
that one of that famous Christmas
parties that used to do at the White
House and he was quite cold actually
Barack Obama as I would be by standing
meeting thousands of people for a
picture uh she was incredibly warm
friendly you know funny whatever uh
formidably impressive actually as an
operator her books sold gazillions of
copies she's kind of widely respected is
it a mad idea I mean I look at Joe Biden
and think walking cors of course she
she's very likable obviously the only
question is why would she want to do
that to her well I don't think she does
she doesn't and I wouldn't either if I
her because as you mention she is widely
respected she is charming people enjoy
her people respect her and that will all
change if you become the president
nobody exits that being more widely l
you've been a politician she has been
through the full forensic examination as
first lady for eight years she's used to
that I mean I've heard mad ideas I got
to say she's a very likable woman I met
her too at the Kennedy Center Awards for
Jimmy pagee she was as you say lovely
Charming I don't care what your politics
are very affable she's got no political
experience whatsoever and I think it's
difficult for the Democrats to who like
to say Trump was a disaster look at this
celebrity never run a never run a bath
and yet somehow he's going to be
president of the United States while he
did a terrible job and then you're going
to put in a first lady who's never been
elected to the Town Council please
somebody like Amy kobar it certainly
wouldn't go automatically to carela
Harris um and that's the way the cookie
crumbles but look you got two old men
running for president both parties need
to have a plan for if either one of them
has a heart attack on the campaign Trail
and dies yeah absolutely well thank you
Pat that was obviously brilliant because
you're a brilliant pack I appreciate it
uncensored next Nikki Haley finished
third in the Iowa caucus but still
declared it's a two-person race and that
she's in it not Ronda sandz can she
really stop Donald Trump I'll talk to
one of her fiercest Advocates Governor
Chris anuna next sunsense
[Music]
live we're here thanks for joining us
you're with talk TV on TV on radio
online we're on your smart speaker as
well you know what I love about talk
today we do it all soon sella
scon I rather like David Cameron I don't
sort of bear him any ill will because he
delivered the referendum that he said he
would deliver the tor's love a scrap you
can almost see this coming around the
tracks with sella bravman she's heading
up one side and richy soon at the other
the police are pro Palestine that is
just not right you swearing off in the
police to act without fear or favor the
co inquiry seems to have turned into a
sort of pantomim there's not really any
substance to it it's hard whether it's a
fce or a tragedy there needs to be one
human per machine to come and rectify
beeps and the clanks and when it goes
wrong unexpected item in bagging area I
know are we only going to be trusting
sources like meta and Google where is
our unbiased news going to come from
Gram was president of the Cambridge unit
which is the rubbish version of being
president of the Oxford
unit Kevin O Sullivan is the worst
presenter on talk TV sitting on his fat
ass talking
living if you're walking towards me and
you're a vegan you have a great big
orange sticker over here saying watch
out vegan's about Twitter you sons of
can you please reinstate my hand thank
you this is a major Summit President
Biden decided this was important after
watching a Tom Cruz
film kids think all they have to do is
take pictures of everything just shut
down Tik Tok problem solve when I say I
am God I'm not joking did you feel Elvis
was controlling I've been answering your
question you answer mine it's actually
not my job to answer your question are
you prepared to call h a terror group is
it possible to have a
r talk TV is the only place where you
get the
truth this is talk
[Music]
TV
welcome back to uncensored live from New
York City Donald Trump mumai landsliding
Iowa a Monumental boost of course for
his bid to return to the W house dicki
Haley finished an hour third by Ronda
Sanz but she still said
this I can safely say tonight Iowa made
this Republican primary a twers
race well as the primaries move on to
New Hampshire I'm joined by the esteemed
governor of New Hampshire Chris senu the
only current governor or Senator so far
to publicly endorse Nikki Haley well
Governor great to see you um she seems
very confident for somebody who came
third that it's a two horse race with
her in it why is is your preferred
candidate so
confident because Des santis left the
building I mean Ron has has left New
Hampshire he has no money he has no
staff he's not even comp he's literally
not competing here he's uh just made an
announcement short time ago that he's
going to South Carolina Nikki home state
so I'm not sure what he's thinking he's
going to get there no this is a
two-person race this is Trump versus
Haley all the polls say so um it's still
I mean there's you know some poll's had
her tied and everything but there's
still a lot of work to do no one thought
Trump could even be challenged uh to be
defeated in one of these early States
Nikki is actually doing it and I think
that's why there's a lot of momentum so
no it's it's clearly a two-person race
and as much as Ron might not say
publicly I think they they see the
writing on the wall as well if you're
right and uh certainly New Hampshire and
South Carol look look like potentially
much stronger areas for Nikki Haley and
Ronda santz what is the path for Nikki
Haley to try and stop the Trump train
which has clearly got off to a rattling
Good
Start sure so let's start with the Trump
voter right so right now if you pull
Trump voters and the number one reason
why folks are are getting behind uh
Trump the the most common answer given
is well he's going to win anyway right
so I guess we'll just vote for him um
you have that 35% core Trump voter of
course but a lot of folks are just kind
of going with them because they assume
it's presumptive it's the fatea complete
it's not and as soon as you I think you
shatter that that that um that
opportunity that Trump has kind of taken
advantage of that it's just my party and
I'm running away with it everyone starts
looking at this as a two-person race you
go into a place like super Tuesday as a
su as a two-person race you know Trump
would in some of those States he's not
even holding 50% well last time I
checked in a two-person race if you
can't get 50% you lose
so that's why Trump attacking Nikki he's
spending all the money is it not in
Nikki Haley's interest for Ronda santz
to stay in as long as possible and I'll
explain what I what I think that may be
the case is that vate ramaswami has
pulled out most of his votes will
probably go now to Trump because he's
he's he's all he's backed him um if
Ronda santis was to pull out then you
got to assume that a large number of his
would also move to Trump so how does
that help Nikki Haley if Ronda Sanz
pulls out tactically is it not better if
he just lips on for a
bit yeah no look it's folks are always
trying to judge where voters will go um
in the case of V I think you're
absolutely right most of those will
probably become Trump voters because V
is crazy he's a conspiracy theorist
crazy guy um most of the Chris Christie
voters are very anti-trump so most of
them are going to Galvanize about around
the candidate most likely to defeat
Trump so that's going to be Nikki Haley
in the case of Ron it's a little I I
don't know what what what it would be so
I'm not going to presume where where his
voters would go um the big thing that
we're focusing on here in New Hampshire
and I think ultimately will have to
happen in South Carolina is getting out
the vote right where Iowa fell really
flat a 100 what what Trump get like
56,000 votes 56,000 people out of over
three million in Iowa dictated that
Trump was going to be the nominee
whereas in New Hampshire again we'll
have a much higher voter turnout so the
higher the voter turn out the more
likely Nikki is to defeat Trump right
because every new vote that comes to the
table is more likely to be Nikki so I
don't think they're worrying more about
the four or five% of of the disantis
voters and where they go it's about
driving another 10 or 20% higher on the
voter turnout knowing that that would
definitely help uh you know that never
fares well for the incumbent and that's
effectively what Trump is he's
effectively an incumbent in this race as
the former president he almost tries to
convince people he wasn't already
president and didn't already get a lot
of stuff not done um but that that's
that's the situation so that's really
where where we're we're focusing a lot
of our effort I met Nikki Hy for the
first time actually in this building uh
we were both on Hannity last time I was
in New York a couple of months ago and
we had a nice long conversation I was
very impressed she has a very nice way
about it she's very engaging very smart
very Charming um she hasn't given me an
interview yet so maybe you could put a
good word in for me after this Governor
I'd appreciate it but we'll move on from
that terrible snub uh so far um but I
was impressed by her but a lot of people
on the Republican side who are not
necessarily uh her biggest fans say that
she's too liberal she's not a proper
conservative not a real Republican you
know her very well what do you say to
those
people too liberal she she's a she was
the Tea Party Conservative candidate
when she became governor of South
Carolina uh in 2010 and then again in
2014 so no she's she's as conservative
as they come and that's I mean her
credentials as being fiscally
conservative much more fiscally
conservative than Trump Trump's a
disaster when it comes to fiscal
conservatism uh individual liberties
which we pride a lot here in New
Hampshire right that the individual
comes first not big Government Solutions
which Trump tries to do out of DC that
doesn't Fair too well with conservatives
in the Live Free or Die state to be sure
um uh decentralizing the Department of
Education so again States localities
individuals parents have more control
over what's happening in the classroom
Trump didn't do any of that right so she
brings these amazing conservative
credentials and the best one is she gets
stuff done right she regardless to where
you are on the policy she gets stuff
done she has a record of doing it
balancing budgets all that sort of thing
um bringing Healthcare reform I was
promised Healthcare reform from Donald
Trump we didn't get it right she takes
these challenges on and she actually
solves things so at the end of the day
that's what conservatives want they want
government that actually moves forward
decentralizes and again lets the
individual come first as you head
towards New Hampshire is she going to
take the gloves off now and start
pounding Trump because it seems to me
the only way anybody is going to
actually take Trump down is to start
pounding him properly and there's
obviously lots of ammunition you could
go for but rather like every other
candidate it looks like Nikki Haley has
has held off doing this because she's
worried about aggravating his very loyal
supporters no so a couple things there
so let's look at the Chris Christie
Chris Christie threw everything and the
kitchen sink at Donald Trump and never
got past 133% so to say that we're just
going to hit Trump harder and that will
work Chris tried it it was an
interesting strategy one state strategy
clearly did not work um and it it it
again you kind of hit a cap there Nikki
doesn't overthink it she is who she is
she'll call Trump out on January 6 and
on electional and all this stuff but
good candidates talk about what they're
bringing to the table not just what the
what the other guy isn't and what the
other guy hasn't done right leave it to
surrogates like us to complain about
Trump Nikki's all about herself and and
she's happy to hit him she's worked very
closely with him for many many years
right but she understands that she wants
to talk about what she's going to do to
fix this country the solutions she's
going to bring her experience her
experience in internationally unmatched
Trump can't match her experience
internationally he showed up at the
meetings taking all the policy decisions
from her and the Department of State
what she's done working with legislators
so this is an amazing candidate with
amazing credentials and as you say most
importantly she's just likable she's
super gen she definitely she's
definitely likable but what if she's so
likable that she gets flatlined in New
Hampshire Trump barrels through and has
another massive Victory can you continue
past that if that was to happen
sure well look going to our home state
of South Carolina there's there's huge
opportunities there so in the first
three states of Iowa New Hampshire and
South Carolina there's only one person
that has to win all three and that's
Trump he's the only one that has set the
expectations that he's going to run away
with it in all three states so anything
different than that whether it's beating
him or coming in a close second that
that challenges that whole narrative
that presumption that's out there so
whether it happens in New Hampshire New
Hampshire I think it will New Hampshire
and South Carolina that builds momentum
in that two person race then you hit
super Tuesday right with a one-on-one
race going into Super Tuesday I think
anything's on the table okay and if you
would tell uh Nikki Haley that I'm here
tomorrow we have a slot if she fancies
an interview we'd happily take it
Governor s thank you very
much you bet thank you
buddy and say the next Donald Trump call
for Unity in his Iowa victory speech but
can he actually deliver Unity it wasn't
much sign of it last time he was
President I'll talk to one of his
biggest backers the Arizona Senate
candidate at carry Lake the uncensored
next live from New
[Music]
York we're here thanks for joining us
you're with talk TV on TV on radio
online onun your smart speaker as well
criminals to using XL Bully dogs as
weapons to threaten others no matter how
well trained most dog owners will tell
you a dog can turn do you know what I
love about talk today we do it all sunak
sella scun
I rather like David Cameron I don't sort
of bear him any ill will because he
delivered the referendum that he said he
would deliver the tor's love a scrap you
can almost see this coming around the
tracks with sella bravman she's heading
up one side and richy soon at the
other the police are pro Palestine that
is just not right you swear an o in the
police to act without fear or favor the
co inquiry seems to have turned into a
sort of pantomim there's not really any
substance to it it's hard to know
whether it's a fce or a tragedy
the amount of time it's taken the number
of illegal migrants currently sent by us
to Rwanda zil the amount of money it's
cost we're saying what are we saying
it's cost about 140 million 140 million
so far so £40 million so far result nil
absolutely nil are we only going to be
trusting sources like meta and Google
where is our unbiased news going to come
from Kell in winter is
cold that is from the Jeremy Corbin B
Kevin O Sullivan is the worst presenter
on talk TV sitting on his fat ass
talking if you're walking towards me and
you're a vegan you have a great big
orange sticker over here saying watch
out vegan's
about the weirdest plank that we've had
in three years hundreds and hundreds of
mice in a box which he walks into a
branch of McDonald MC Mouse man mcmouse
man MC mous man he should be easy enough
to catch this guy shouldn't he I mean
he's got house full of
mice this is a major President Biden
decided this was important after
watching a Tom Cruz
film sunak and the current conservative
government are not conservative why
don't you leave that party and come to
one that actually shares your ideology
this has been a party political
broadcast on behalf reform UK
party kids think all they have to do is
take pictures of everything just shut
down Tik Tok problem solve this is
really unfair what what what's unfair if
it's on camera when not doing interviews
yes I'm going to do you're going to
resign yes cuz I cannot continue my work
when I say I am God I'm not joking did
you feel Elvis was controlling I've been
answering your question you answer mine
it's actually not my job to answer your
questions are you prepared to call teror
group is it possible to have a rational
I've asked you two questions should a
mass stay in power and are they a terror
group you're refusing to answer either
of them that is very telling talk TV is
the only place where you get the truth
you've done a book on poetry poetry and
music for the many I love poetry we can
agree on
[Music]
that welcome back to uncensored live
from New York City Donald Trump has
sounded well was presidential in recent
proclamations calling for Unity in the
party and the country that may have
brought repeal in the presidential
election and the vengeful election
denying rants we become accustomed to
but can it last which Trump is running
for president the unifier or the divider
here to hopefully shed some light is one
of his biggest supporters who also got a
shout out in his Iowa victory speech the
Arizona Senate candidate and friend of
the show Carrie Lake Carrie good to see
you how are you it's great to be back
thank you for having me on today Pierce
well you just heard a very good pitch
for why Nikki Haley uh is in a two-horse
race now with Donald Trump and he made a
compelling argument I think Governor
sonunu that if you look at the path of
New Hampshire and South Carolina you got
to say it favors her over DeSantis do
you agree with him this couldn't end up
quite quickly as a two- horse race you
know I think we're going through some
formalities I think president Trump is
already the nominee and uh the American
people understand that but it's it's a
little bit of an ego trip for um for the
others and a vanity project and I guess
we just have to wait until they come to
grips with reality that President Trump
will be the nominee and he's going to
lead us back to our greatest days here
in America with a secure border and a
great economy and frankly World Peace
which I think the whole world will
benefit from are we going to get the
Trump that we heard in his Iowa victory
speech which was far more unifying he's
very complimentary about his Rivals he
was very unifying in his language about
bringing Independence and Democrats
together with Republicans which is what
a lot of average Americans I think are
crying out for an enter the toxic
tribalism and a more unified country is
that the Donald Trump we may see if he
won a second term do you think I I think
we will see that and you know I didn't
hear that from the others that were
running in their speeches on Monday
night they were very much still
attacking president Trump and and his uh
the folks who support him but president
Trump does want to bring this country
together I talked to him quite often and
in his policies he did bring this
country together you have to remember
when he was President Pierce we had an
incredible economy we had the lowest
unemployment rate in the entire time
I've been alive and that means
unemployment rates were low for black
Americans Latino Americans
asian-americans white Americans his
policies were unifying because they
helped improve the lives of all
Americans and we had a secure border we
weren't being overrun with people
invading our our country illegally
coming into our country and uh taking
away from Americans who are many of them
homeless on the streets and we're
watching right now as Joe Biden
continues to put the needs of people
who've come here illegally ahead of
American citizens so Trump will put the
American people first what if he's in
prison I mean genuine question he's
facing 91 criminal charges what if he's
convicted of one or some of those
charges and actually gets put into a
prison cell I mean it could happen under
the Constitution he would still be able
to run the country but would that be a
good
thing we've seen the witch hunts they've
been going on since president Trump had
the courage to step into the political
Arena there's been one Witch Hunt after
the next and most of it fueled by the
media sadly and even if he was sitting
in Alcatraz the people will vote for him
because they know that he is going to
put America First and in the last three
years under Joe Biden we've watched as
America has been put last we've learned
how he's taken payouts and vibes from um
some of our adversaries and we are all
suffering because of it and we just want
to get policies back that put our
country first strengthen our families
strengthen our border and strengthen our
security decent energy policy here's the
problem I wrote a column yesterday uh in
which I extol the landslide Victory it
was it was spectacular it's an amazing
comeback story on furling with Donald
Trump but in the weeds of some of the
data were some concerning numbers like
30% of Republicans when are said that
they would not support him if he was
convicted of a crime that's a big number
of Republicans you got to assume that
percentage would go up with Independence
who would be crucial to him potentially
winning a general election are you not
concerned about that I mean it may well
be as you say all a liberal Witch Hunt
um or it may not but if he's actually
convicted it does seem like many
Republicans would be deterred and may
prefer to then pivot to another
candidate well you're always going to
have those Republicans who have Trump
derangement syndrome and I think they
will eventually start to come around as
we get closer to the election I've
looked at the polls actually I've been
following them very closely and
president Trump is the only Republican
who can win and can beat um Biden or
whomever they put forth as their
candidate the others can't win and
you've got to have the Trump supporters
behind you to get a victory and the
Trump supporters uh dedication to
president Trump because they know that
he's helped us they know that he's put
us first his support is a mile deep
these other guys support is about an
inch deep and it won't
last if he wants to win a general
election why should any of us accept the
result why shouldn't we just all pull a
trump and say no not having it never
happened the other guy got Biden got
stolen got robbed and just keep saying
that for the entire tenure of Trump's
second term I mean seriously why
shouldn't Americans just not me but
Americans just return the favor yeah we
heard that in 2016 remember Hillary um
was the original election denier that's
the term they use we've all been called
that and this is one of the reasons
Pierce why I've been pushing and working
really hard to bring about election
reform because frankly since 2000 we've
had elections where one year it'll be
the Democrats saying they don't think it
was fair the next time it's the
Republicans we have the ability to make
our election so fair that we wake up the
next day after the election and everyone
can live with the results because they
know it was fair and that's why I
continue to push to try to reform our
election so that Democrats feel
comfortable and believe in the results
Independents and Republicans and I think
pres problem car we we we've debated
this before but my problem with that is
to any independent eye they have been
Fair your election Trump's election uh
they were fair and most senior
Republicans have accepted this and to
continue bleeting about having an
election robbed makes it difficult for
you to then claim victory doesn't it in
elections well I I will point out that I
um you brought up the whole topic so it
was your topic that you brought up and
asked me about and I just answered so I
think we're going to work to bring about
reform I mean I think more and more
Americans are realizing that U mailin
ballots and having them float around out
there for a month and voting for a month
and Counting votes for two weeks is a is
a recipe for fraud to seep into our
elections and I think all we want is
really Fair elections that everybody
feels comfortable with they have made a
statement condemning Hamas we expect to
see the crown revisit Harry's
anti-semitic Halloween costume criminals
to using XL Bully dogs as weapons to
threaten others no matter how well
trained most dog owners will tell you a
dog can turn you know what I love about
talk today we do it all sunak sella
scon I rather like David Cameron I don't
sort of bear him any ill will because he
delivered the referendum that he said he
deliver the Israelis are very
conciliatory all they want is to be
recognized the timing of this hamus
attack comes because there was the
expectation there was going to be a deal
down to normalizing relations with Saudi
Arabia the Tories love a scrap you can
almost see this coming around the tracks
with sella bravman she's heading up one
side and richy soon at the other
reshuffles usually very dull this one
had booster Rockets attached to it
certainly the tone has shifted in terms
of what Rashi sunak has done the
question now is what he does next the
police Pro Palestine that is just not
right you swear an o in the police to
act without fear or favor the co inquiry
seems to have turned into a sort of
pantomim there's not really any
substance to it it's hard to know
whether it's a fce or a tragedy talk TV
has spoken exclusively to a member of
the Blade Runners do you have a message
for sadik Khan we're not stopping until
you
stop the amount of time it's taken the
number of illegal migrants currently
sent by us to Rwanda zil the amount of
money it's cost with saying what are we
saying it's cost about 140 million £140
million so far so £140 million so far
result nil absolutely nil are we only
going to be trusting sources like meta
and Google where is our unbiased news
going to come from K in winter is
cold that is from the Jeremy Corbin book
Kevin O Sullivan is the worst presenter
on talk TV sitting on his fat ass
talking if you're walking towards me and
you're a vegan you have a great big
orange sticker over here saying watch
out vegan's
about the weirdest plank that we've had
in three years hundreds and hundreds of
mice in a box which he walks into a
branch of McDonald MC mous man MC Mouse
man MC mous man he should be easy enough
to catch this guy shouldn't he I mean
he's got house full of
mice this is a major Summit President
Biden decided this was important after
watching a Tom Cruz film do you think
people underestimate how important music
is for this country